(upbeat music)
- And now, here's something neat
that I wanted you all to see.
Take a look.
- Hi, Drew, it's Liz of Eat Cake Be Merry
and I wanna share with you
how to create these
adorable puppy cupcakes.
First, you'll want to shape some fondant
to create the ears, eyes, tongue and nose.
Then color some buttercream and
place them into piping bags.
Now grab a cupcake, and using a grass tip,
pipe lines that extend
from the center out.
Go ahead and cover the entire surface
of the cupcake with fur.
Once you've done that,
let's create some of the
puppy's facial features.
Now you can add both ears,
angle them just a little,
two eyes, a cute nose, and
of course, a pink tongue.
Let's add some twinkle to
those precious puppy eyes.
So adorable. Isn't it just the cutest?
Let's bring in some friends.
There you have a fun and easy way
to create the cutest cupcakes.
- Hi, Drew, it's Pati Jinich.
To help celebrate Hispanic Heritage Month,
I'm gonna make a salsa matcha,
and it's gorgeous and so delicious.
It's from my upcoming book,
"Treasures of the Mexican Table."
And to make it, all you
need is five minutes
and you can use it in so many ways.
So I'm gonna add olive oil, vegetable oil.
Once it's hot, add walnuts,
pine nuts, pistachios,
garlic cloves, ancho chiles,
stem them, seed them,
cut them into small pieces,
and chiles de arbol.
So you're gonna stem them.
I'm gonna keep the seeds,
and then I'm gonna stir.
Add pumpkin seeds,
amaranth seeds, vinegar,
dark brown sugar, salt.
Mix these up, and we're gonna let it cool.
You can spoon it on top of avocado toast.
You can spoon it on top
of pancakes, French toast.
You can spoon it on top of yogurt, fruit.
You can eat it in so many ways.
It's super yum.
- Hi Drew, I'm Capri Lily,
creator of Good Food Baddie.
And today I'll be showing you how to make
these spooky pumpkin ice
cream cookie sandwiches.
Here I have homemade double
chocolate chip cookies
and they're gonna serve as the base
for our pumpkin ice
cream cookie sandwiches.
Right now, I'm gonna show you how to make
your own pumpkin ice cream at home.
I'm gonna start off by
adding the pumpkin puree.
Then I'll add coconut cream,
maple syrup, pumpkin spice,
cinnamon, coconut sugar,
and blend until it's smooth.
Then I'll place it in the bread pan
and place it in the freezer for two hours.
And now I have this delicious, smooth,
creamy pumpkin spice ice cream.
Now we'll take a scoop of the ice cream
and place it on top of our
double chocolate chip cookies
and then use another cookie
to finish and complete the sandwich.
And we're all done.
We have these spooky pumpkin spice
ice cream cookie sandwiches.
(upbeat music)